I
well i was born in northern ireland born
there in 1951 brought up in the 50s and
60s to some extent insofar as i was
brought up in ireland so that of course
was a major component in terms of the
mindset and what of course impinged i
suppose mostly mostly had to do with the
political situation in northern ireland
the state the altered state or some
would have it that was set up basically
because a united Ireland as it was then
conceived was not manageable in the
early 1920s so there was a sense of
course always of some sort of unfinished
business in during my childhood it's not
as if I was conscious of violence on the
streets though mind you in the 1950s as
of course more notoriously from the late
60s on there was an IRA campaign so I
remember quite vividly as a child being
brought well actually stumbling upon
with my father and neighbor or to a site
where that obviously been some digging
going on probably probably for an arm's
dump or something along those lines
because one promptly forgot about it
there was a sense of the British Army on
the roads of course there was a sense of
the be specials as they were known so as
not to confuse them with the air
specials the auxiliary police force
helping out the Royal anster
Constabulary as it was known and helping
the bite at night often farmers
neighbors predominantly Protestant
police force help helping helping Artie
are you see and stopping
catholic neighbors asking though they
were what their business was what their
title was indeed though they knew
perfectly well what what that was so
there was a sense of all that and mind
you having said that it was a
terrifically as I remember it any high
actually quite a joyous childhood I was
brought up in the countryside I had a
countryside that then certainly in that
part of the world was still predominate
predominantly a little one little field
after another over growing hedgerows
full of little birds cheeping away most
of or at least many of which of now of
course gone the way of all bird flesh
they've been poisoned one way or another
of the land has been cleared in ways
that were unimaginable then built up in
all sorts of ways so the place of course
was was County Armagh but halfway across
Northern Ireland an apple growing
district a district where some of the
people who plant who had been planted
there in the Elizabethan era had come
from Warwickshire and brought with them
their apple plans but also much of the
language which of course William
Shakespeare was using and which was
fossilized where I was brought up so my
father for example would use expressions
like I'll warrant I warned what was I
thinking of the other day various
expressions that really have fallen into
disuse in most other parts of the world
but which were continued to be current
where I was brought up was a sense to
the Irish language in that in the back
of the mind or perhaps not even quite so
far back as the back of the mind to the
to the forefront of the mind
and all the place names again were
fossilized versions of gaelic place
names in many cases so you know even the
place names college lands the school I
went to refer to an area of property
that had belonged to trinity college
dublin when when trinity owned that land
the the immediate townland was known as
Keenen Keenen which means a mossy boggy
place which was an accurate enough
description of where we were so you know
this is just a little smattering of
Earth they the back the backdrop as it
were and the back of the mind but all of
that going on there
what a political sense it was i suppose
the characterized that one would say we
were nationalists thus to say that we
did think of ireland as being a
continuum let's aim being good being you
know essentially 11 culture one place
i'm not sure if we were entirely right
in thinking that i mean because while
it's well it is a small place and when
there is much that is continuous about
it it's actually a very various place to
despite its size astonishingly one can
drive particularly nowadays as they
paved it over from one end of it to the
other it comfortably within a day drive
across it in an afternoon so one has to
have that sense of the scale of the
place really above all and that cause
that sense of the scale of the place
does you know begin to allowing one to
make sense of the the political bank
ride so we were nationalists to within
the irish context one would use that
term of the Catholic as we were the
Catholic community rather than
Republicans though in that sense the
Irish the sense of an Irish Republic was
there but without the the armed struggle
component as it's known that's to say we
were we were raised as nonviolent non
militant nationalists so the area in
which I was brought up though was an
area to which we moved and when I was a
bunch for so we were always something of
outsiders my mother was a schoolteacher
which put her somewhat beyond the pale
to use that great Irish notion you
even more so the fact that we were
blowing as they say we were foreigners
in other words we come from about 15
miles up the road which despite the fact
whatever that one can drive from one end
of Ireland to the other in a day as I've
just been saying 15 miles is like an
atlantic spread you know what might as
well be we going to Venus so the the
area in which I was brought up was an
area notable then for many families that
were indeed engaged in you who were
Republicans of the of the the militant
school so that I went to school for
example with my mother taught I was a
school beside boys and girls who turned
out to be involved in the in the the
armed struggle as they as they refer to
it in Ireland and many of them died blew
themselves up were shot
so that was the back
you